avant de décliner l'actualité de la
matinée le drôle de drame du tgv 8540 9
paris bordeaux 2 heures de retard parce
qu'un passager avait le bras coincé dans
la cuvette des toilettes
une histoire à la jerry lewis jean-paul
boom qui est reine à l'origine le train
à destination de toulouse via bordeaux
n'aurait pas dû s'arrêter en gare de
saint pierre des corps mais il a bien
fallu stopper le temps de dégager un
passage est quelque peu ennuyé son bras
était point c'est jusqu'au coude dans
les toilettes son portefeuille était
tombé dans la cuvette il a voulu le
récupérer lui même mal lui en a pris le
clapet s'est refermé sur le bras il a
donc fallu appeler les pompiers de tours
qui ont dû découper la cuvette pour
dégager le voyageur et l'emmener à
l'hôpital
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là le tgv
auquel il manquait désormais un morceau
ne pouvait pas repartir il a fallu faire
venir une autre rame de paris bilan pour
les voyageurs trois heures de retard des
voyageurs parmi lesquels se trouvait un
certain jerry lewis en personne l'acteur
a pris la chose avec philosophie
peut-être même un brin de jalousie
jamais ce gag ne lui était venu à l'idée
pour l'un de ses films
[Musique]